bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de checkup votre
magazine santé et bien-être c'est un
classique à l'approche de l'été la ch au
kilo en trop bas sont plein pourtant
certaines méthodes sont dangereuses pour
la santé avec nous sur le plateau le
docteur Sylvie Tiano bonjour bonjour
vous êtes médecin généraliste de
formation mais vous exercez aujourd'hui
dans un cabinet de médecine esthétique
vous nous expliquerez à tout à l'heure
de quoi il s'agit mais avant regardons
ensemble le sommaire l'UFR des Sciences
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin va bénéficier d'une
dotation supplémentaire grâce au Conseil
Général 9,5 million d'euros dont 4
millions réservés pour la Faculté des
sciences de la santé qui ouvrira dès la
rentrée prochaine sur montiné afin de
réduire les dépenses de santé la Cisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des ivelin
mise sur la prévention un Espace Santé
Active visant à répondre aux questions
de santé au quotidien a ouvert récemment
à
poissé je vous le disais à l'approche de
l'été nombreuses sont les personnes à
rechercher un régime rapide et efficace
avez-vous noté une augmentation des
consultation au sein de votre cabinet
allant dans ce sens alors c'est sûr
qu'il existe une saisonnalité il y a
quand même une recrudescence des
demandes qui commencent qui se
léchelonent entre le mois de mars et le
mois de juin mais en ce qui me concerne
ce n'est pas la majorité des cas j'ai
quand même une majorité de personnes qui
sont dans une démarche de recherche de
perte de poids pour leur santé ou parce
qu'elles sont mal dans leur peau mais
pas spécifiquement le petit régime
objectif maillot de bar alors all vite
rime souvent avec restriction on le sait
êtes-vous en accord avec cette méthode
est-ce qu'il est grave par exemple de
sauter un repas alors sur le plan des
restrictions effectivement il faut
savoir que de toute façon il n'y a pas
de secret pour perdre du poids il faut
soit diminuer le nombre de calories que
l'on ingurgite par rapport à ce que l'on
consomme habituellement soit en dépenser
plus et en général c'est donc l'activité
physique donc le problème est de savoir
comment on va diminuer ses calories et
donc comment on va personnaliser ce
régime néanmoins il faut savoir que dans
ces cas-là et c'est l'idéal c'est de
perdre progress du poids la majorité des
personnes souhaitent aller un petit peu
plus vite en besogne et là toute la
difficulté est là parce qu'en fait soit
on leur dit bah non c'est pas bon pour
la santé de mrir trop vite et dans ces
cas-là on risque de les perdre dans la
nature et au final le risque c'est
qu'elle fasse n'importe quoi sur la base
d'Internet de certains magazines ou de
certaines publicités donc on est de
temps en temps quand même obligé entre
guillemets de répondre à leurs demandes
et les aider à perdre du poids un petit
pe rapidement alors justement vous
parliez des magazines la plupart d'entre
eux proposent avant l'été un certain
nombre de régimes minceurs miraculeux
mais l'on sait aujourd'hui que certains
causent des des carences et des
déséquilibres alimentaires est-ce que
vous pouvez nous parler un petit peu de
ces déséquilibres alors il faut savoir
que les régimes qui entraînent le plus
de déséquilibre et de carence sont les
régimes qui entraînent l'éviction totale
d'un ou plusieurs d'une ou plusieurs
catégories d'aliments sachant
qu'aujourd'hui on dispose quand même de
possibilité de complémenter les régimes
donc en micronutriments justement pour
éviter ces carences et puis surtout il
faut savoir les rechercher hein donc ça
c'est aussi ce qu'on va faire dans le
cadre d'une consultation médicale par
opposition à ce qui va être fait lorsque
on suit un régime dans un magazine et
puis il faut aussi rechercher les
problèmes de de santé tout simplement
associés au problème de poids alors on
va parler d'un tout autre sujet l'UFR de
Sciences de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin va bénéficier d'une
dotation supplémentaire de 9,5 millions
d'euros grâce au conseil général on
regarde ces machines valent des millions
d'euros elles pèseent à chacune une
tonne repose sur des dalles antiibration
d'une soixantaine de centimètres et pour
enfoncer le clou scientifique ce sont
des exemplaires uniques qui permettent
d'étudier le cœur de la matière
autrement dit elles font rêver plus d'un
chercheur et c'est à l'UFR des Sciences
de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin qu'elle se trouve et si
elles sont installées ici c'est que leur
achat a étit entièrement fin ancé par un
partenaire public plus connu pour
entretenir les collèges le Conseil
général ça a été financé par le Conseil
général et les ça a permis de développer
tout un axe de recherche qui n'aurait
pas pu être développé notamment et qui
fait que je dirais au niveau national et
international notamment ces compétences
sont des compétences reconnues à
versaill c'est plusieurs millions pour
avoir pour avoir ce type d'équipement
tous les centres de recherche voudraient
avoir des équipements similaires dans
toutes les disciplines donc en effet si
un moment donné on veut développer une
activité dans un territoire je pense que
il est un peu légitime de demander aussi
à ce territoire d'aider ces activités à
se monter si on peut le dire il y a un
certain des engagements de l'État ces
dernières années au au profit ils ont
donc ils sont ils sont passé les
contributions si je puis dire au
collectivité territoriale le Conseil
Général des ivines a en effet injecté
9,5 millions d'euros pour l'UFR des
Sciences c'est un beau cadeau d'autant
plus que l'enseignement supérieur n'est
pas une prérogative du département mais
l'institution y voit bien sûr un intérêt
d'attraction de son territoire il est
important que nous ayons des campus de
grande qualité et puis bien entendu à
terme c'est des créations d'emploi vous
l'avez bien vous l'avez bien compris
parce que les entreprises aiment à
s'installer près de de centes de
recherche parmi l'enveloppe apporté par
le Conseil Général 4 millions sont
réservés pour le nouveau bâtiment des
sciences de la santé qui devrait ouvrir
à montiny à la rentrée 2012 le bâtiment
sera livré brut le 29 juin avant
d'entamer l'aménagement intérieur la
commission de sécurité passera fin
juillet pour un accueil des étudiants de
première année de médecine en
septembre de retour sur le plateau de
checkup pour parler des régimes alors on
parlait en première partie des méthodes
les plus répandu et des risques qu'ell
comportte mais comment savoir en fait si
les kilos en trop ne sont pas tout
simplement dans la tête alors le premier
paramètre qui est je dirais le paramètre
médical le plus souvent utilisé c'est ce
que l'on appelle l'indice de masse
corporelle qui est la mesure du poids
sur la taille au carré donc ça c'est un
paramètre tout à fait objectif et qui
permet de définir poid normal surpoids
et obésité avec ces trois niveaux de de
de gravité il faut savoir que ce
paramètre est tout à fait imparfait
puisqu'en fait il ne prend en compte
comme je vous disais que le poids et la
taille or il ne va pas prendre en compte
donc la répartition de la graisse et la
composition du poids corporel or
certaines personnes vont par exemple
avoir un poids qui se situe dans les
limites de de normal c'est-à-dire un
indice de masse corporelle entre 19 et
25 25 tout en ayant un pourcentage de
graisse beaucoup trop important et puis
a il a été proposé récemment un nouveau
paramètre très simple qui en fait
consiste à dire que le tour de taille
qui est un paramètre très important doit
être inférieur à la moitié de la taille
donc pour quelqu'un qui mesure 1 M60 et
bien il doit avoir un tour de taille
inférieur à 80 cm très bien alors quel
conseil donneriez-vous à une personne
qui souhaite maigrir raisonnablement
étant donné les délais là avant l'été
quelqu'un qui veut perdre à peu près 2 à
4 kg voilà avant l'été bien on peut
quand même lui donner des des petits
conseils simples tout en sachant que il
faudrait là aussi personnalisé en
fonction de chacun de chacun on pourrait
dire quand même que cette personne
aurait tendance à consommer des
protéines matin midi et soir ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas des protéines
de bonne qualité par exemple le matin
avec un petit peu de jambon tout
simplement ou un œuf dans la limite du
raisonnable de consommer des aliments
comme je vous le disais qui ont une
densité énergétique faible c'est-à-dire
en gros qui vont remplir l'estomac mais
qui ne vont pas apporter trop de
calories par gramme donc ça va être le
cas par exemple des légumes donc
commencer un repas et consommer toujours
de bonnes quantités de légumes ensuite
boire de l'eau c'est aussi un petit peu
le le principe de de ce type d'aliment
de remplir l'estomac pour développer la
saciété autre conseil remplacer les
cérales du matin par exemple par des
flocons d'avoine qui vont moins
augmenter le taux de sucre dans le sang
et puis je dirais ben supprimer quand
même les fritures les frites c'est quand
même pas terrible pour la santé ni pour
le poids et puis enfin on pourrait dire
et bien diminuer quand même la quantité
globale de féculant et de pain par
exemple choisir du pain ou un féculant
mais pas les deux au même repas je vous
propose maintenant de regarder notre
second reportage consacré à un espace de
santé active qui a ouvert récemment à
poissie la sécurité sociale cela ne sert
pas qu'à rembourser les soins cela peut
aussi servir d'outil de prévention un
nouvel Espace Santé Active le premier
des ivelines vient d'ouvrir à poissie
ici l'on peut trouver des informations
consulter un centre de documentation via
notamment un cyberespace le but rendre
les gens acteurs de leur santé ce qu'on
veut c'est apporter donc aux assurés des
information qui leur permettent de
devenir acteur de leur santé et de
prendre en charge en fait leur santé il
y a de plus en plus de personnes
aujourd'hui qui ont des maladies lourdes
euh et on souhaite effectivement bah que
les personnes puissent prévenir ces
maladies et fait qu'on puisse diminuer
toutes ces maladies ces ateliers
collectifs seront animés par des
professionnels de santé à compter du 15
juin un atelier par jour sera proposé
d'abord donc sur le thème de
l'alimentation puis sur celui du dos et
du du cœur des enjeux de santé publique
car qui dit prévenir dit mieux guérir et
donc réduire les coûts de l'assurance
maladie moins consommmer de médicaments
moins consulté de médecins une étude
interne démontrerait d'ailleurs qu'un
tel dispositif étendu à l'échelle
nationale pourrait permettre à
l'Assurance Maladie de réaliser 200
millions d'euros d'économie d'autres
antennes santé Activ pourrai ouvrir
notamment à 50 ans en yvelin l'accès
libre et
gratuit
pour en revenir à notre thème principal
les régimes alors vous nous parliez tout
à l'heure des conseils que vous apportez
à vos patient en consultation qu'en
est-il de l'approche comportementale
alors effectivement c'est il faut savoir
que perd du poids ce n'est pas
uniquement une question d'assiette mais
il y a également la tête et ça la
plupart des personnes qui ont justement
subi ce qu'on appelle lesffet yyo le
savent bien ce n'est pas par hasard en
dehors de l'aspect alimentaire qu'elle
reprenneent du poids on constate que
lors d'un régime il y a souvent des
blocages la personne perd 7 8 kg et puis
tout d'un coup elle ne perd plus
indépendamment des blocages liés à des
résistances à des facteurs de poids il y
a souvent des problèmes
psychocomportementaux qui peuvent
intervenir et il est très important de
pouvoir agir sur ces problèmes
psychocomortementaux sans parler de
prise en charge psychologique de
psychothérapie et cetera mais simplement
des petits conseils de thérapie
comportemental peuvent aider parce que
certaines personnes vont tout d'un coup
céder à leurs émotions qui s'agisse de
la colère dans le cas du travail ou
autre alors que jusqu'à maintenant elle
résistait et se se précipiter du coup
sur des aliments qui sont pas forcément
bon pour leur ligne avant de se quitter
un mot peut-être sur les aliments coupef
et la cuisine allégée est-ce une bonne
alternative alors comme je comme je vous
l'ai expliqué les aliments coupf peuvent
tout à fait rentrer dans cette
définition que j'ai donné d'aliments à
faible densité
énergétique après comme je vous l'ai dit
je préfère quand même pouvoir assurer un
c un apport calorique minimal s'il
s'agit pas non plus de crever de faim il
y a rien de pire queun régime dans
lequel on a faim parce que du coup on va
manger n'importe quoi et donc ces
aliments de coup fin sont pour moi une
aide mais c'est vraiment accessoire et
les aliments allégers peuvent aussi
rentrer dans ce contexte là diminution
des apports en glucides rapides surtout
qui sont rapidement et diminution des
apports en Grèce mais ce n'est pas le
principal c'est ainsi que s'achève cette
émission Merci à VOUS docteur Sylvie
Tiano d'avoir accepté notre invitation
quant à nous on se retrouve début
juillet pour un nouveau numéro de
checkup